das kind liegt auf dem bauch am
hinterkopf hat das eisen ein
ordentliches loch reingehauen
ich packe das kind bei den handgelenken
und schleife durch den kies
anscheinend totes kind damit fängt es an
dem debüt roman von michel steinbeck das
kind in den koffer verfrachtet so zählt
ich erzählerin glory bett die schwere
last durchs buch sie sucht den eigenen
vater
denn nichts wissen will vom sperrigen
helber der nächsten generation was ein
älterer mensch und zwar mit nun in
positive sonder einem negativ also was
für angst und wird eigentlich von
älterer mitgehen und treibt somit sich
immer und wie kann man sich davor lösen
steinbecks die büste ein ungestümes
gespickt mit der morbiden bilder ganze
schweine und kühe hängen vor den
geschäften die fleischfetzen ihre säbel
am stein krisen
es ist heiß und durch die luft die nach
gewürzen und pisse riecht zieht der chor
auch den koffer abzuliefern entwickelt
sich zum rasanten abenteuer in dem die
mutige laurie bett von rachsüchtigen
doggen gejagt wird und blut getränkte
kinderfinger futtert so wird der leser
durch steinbecks traumwelten
geschleudert wo alles nicht recht
zusammen finden machen das kind wird zu
lorient ct und so zum sinnbild einer
ungewissen zukunft
auch jener der autorin wald.de
als vater bleibt letztlich unerreichbar
und so fragt man sich nach der lektüre
ob die schwere last die heutige reise
wert war
[Musik]